[Music]
I'm at the eye doctor I'm always at the
eye doctor it's like this is my
profession I'm no longer a writer I'm
now an Optima logical patient by the way
this job doesn't pay well morning egg
it's a Tuesday April 10 Hank that was
noted American nerdfighter Ethan younger
man the creator of the sublet experiment
a play that is probably going to be
performed inside my apartment I tried to
pop it but it just got mad I don't know
about you but I actually kind of do
consider myself a role model at least in
some ways I mean I'm cognizant of the
fact that there are young people
watching this show including like
three-year-olds by the way wasn't an
adorable when a three-year-old commenter
said your punishment should be having to
build a house I want a baby they do such
cute things it's inevitable that your
behavior is shaped by the people around
you whether that means that people
physically around you like your parents
and your siblings and your friends and
coworkers
or whether that means the people who are
only virtually around you like say
Lindsay Lohan or Cristiano Ronaldo
so I do think you have to be cognizant
of the way that your behavior is helping
shape the behavior of other people and
also the way that your own behavior is
being shaped by the other people around
you that's why I'm not reading Paris
Hilton calm anymore it started to make
my brain go gooey and then the goo tried
to come out of my eye and then I almost
went blind but Hank I do agree that a
simplistic notion of role modelling is
stupid for instance I don't think that
anyone's going to be driven to drink by
the fact that you went to a party on
Holy Saturday and then had a hangover on
Easter Sunday the fact of the matter is
that the way that we model behavior for
the people around us in the way that
they model behavior for us is a hell of
a lot more complicated than just wanting
to do what they do and wanting not to do
what they don't do for instance the fact
that Britney Spears seems to be addicted
to methamphetamine makes me less likely
to use methamphetamine not more likely
because I don't want to end up like
Britney Spears this topic has been much
on my mind lately because I received a
series of emails last week from
teenagers asking me the same question
what is my opinion of drunk
driving what is my opinion of drunk
driving I'm opposed to it who the hell
isn't opposed to drunk driving drunk
drivers and jerks that's in that's the
whole list I'm not a drunk driver I
don't even know in a car and I'm not a
jerk ergo I am naturally opposed to
drunk driving and here we get to the
real crux of the matter I think if we
spent the next 365 days making a video
blog that discussed nothing except for
the perils of drunk driving it would
suck in my opinion the question of
whether or not people should drive drunk
they shouldn't is an important question
it's just not a very interesting
question there are lots of things that
are important that don't make good
subjects for books for example the
proper way to perform a push-up is not
an interesting topic for fiction the
price of musics is important but I don't
want to read a book about it
I think what's true for fiction is also
broadly speaking true for video blogs so
that's my opinion on the matter I think
all nerdfighters are role models but I
don't think we should be role models in
boring ways and also I think we all need
to remember the importance of decreasing
world suck in the end I don't think
drinking a few beers at a party
increases or decreases world suck it may
decrease worldsuck briefly for the time
that you're at the party but it will
increase world suck tomorrow when you're
hungover and I think that's okay I mean
with things as they are being world suck
neutral is pretty impressive Hank I'll
see you tomorrow